- Hi, I'm Meaghan from Khan Academy
and in this video,
we're going to walk you
through the learner,
or student, experience.
At Kahn Academy, we believe
that everyone is a learner.
From the teacher perspective,
all of your students are
learners and you can be as well.
To better understand the student
experience on Khan Academy,
log into your Khan Academy account.
Then select the navigation
button indicated by your name,
on the top right of the screen.
Once you see the dropdown
menu, select Learner home.
You can now see the learner
homepage on your screen.
You can think of this as
the student's homepage,
as this is what students see
immediately when they log
into Khan Academy.
Also, a quick tip.
If the student clicks on
the Khan Academy logo,
no matter what page they are on,
assuming they are logged in,
they will always be taken
back to this homepage.
If you've never visited this page before,
you will need to select
at least one course
from a pop-up box screen,
before you will see a
screen similar to this one.
On the left-hand side,
any classes that the student is in
and where the teacher
has given them some sort
of assignment or goal, is listed.
As you can see, the course mastery goal
and assignments
recommended by the teacher,
are accessible with a single click.
Within the Assignments tab,
learners can easily see
upcoming assignments
and work directly on the
assignments from there.
Within the Course mastery tab,
learners can see the mastery
goals you have given them
and their progress towards those goals.
By going to the Progress tab,
they can see their activity log.
The same report is also available
to you as a teacher when you click
into a student on your roster.
We surface the report to
both student and teacher
to facilitate accountability
and teacher-student
conferencing on progress.
By clicking on Teachers,
students can see all of
their current teachers
and also join a new class
by entering a class code.
On this page, students
will find the summary
of their recent activity,
energy points and badges earned.
When students click on their mastery goal,
they are taken to the course
page where they can work
through the course at their own pace.
Courses are considered complete
when a student reaches course
mastery of 90% or more,
and they always have the option
to go back and view past goals.
What you see here
on the course page are the different units
that make up the course,
as well as the student's progress
towards mastering each unit.
Below the unit name are the
lessons within the unit.
By clicking into a lesson or unit,
I am taken to the unit page.
Students have the option here
to either dive straight into practice,
which is listed on the right-hand side
or first check out the learning material,
which are the articles and
videos on the left-hand side.
There are a couple different
types of practice content
in Khan Academy's mastery system.
Exercises, which are
opportunities for students
to learn single skills in isolation
or assessments, where students
get mixed skill review.
The different types
of assessments, address
different quantities of content.
Quizzes are mixed review
of skills in a lesson,
unit tests are mixed review of
skills within an entire unit.
(dynamic, light tone)
Course challenges are
mixed review of skills
from the entire course.
(dynamic, light tone)
As students work through the content,
Khan Academy assesses their skill level,
giving them a designation
of, "Attempted, Familiar,
Proficient or Master."
These levels are surfaced in
the teacher progress reports,
but students can also quickly
understand their level
by looking at the tower
visual next to each skill.
One brick for "Familiar."
Two for "Proficient."
And the crown is unlocked at "Mastered."
When students work on skills
in isolation through exercises,
the maximum level they
can get to is Proficient.
They would need to answer all questions
in isolated skill
practice correctly to get
to that level.
(dynamic, light tone)
The only way to get to Mastered,
is by proving students
can ace questions related
to that skill in a mixed skill context.
So they need to complete the assessments
for that final level up.
If students have tried the skill
and get 70 to 99% correct,
we call them, "Familiar."
If they got less than 70% correct,
then they are "Attempted."
At the top a course page,
students may also see mastery challenges.
Mastery challenges are a
way for students to review
and practice previously
learned skills in a course.
They first get unlocked
after the student has gotten
to the Familiar state
on three or more skills
and continue to get unlocked
once every 12 hours afterwards.
They also provide another
way beyond unit tests
and course challenges for
students to level up or down
in already familiar skills.
(dynamic, light tone)
Mastery challenges highlight
opportunities for students
to engage in personalized space repetition
of the skills students have
already started practicing.
Research shows that
spiraling skills over time
and cross lessons is a key component
to minimizing student learning loss
and improving knowledge retention.
Students can see assignments from teachers
from their learner homepage as well.
From the learner homepage,
students can select assignments
from the left-hand panel under each class.
Students will see current
assignments in the order
of what is due soonish,
at the top of the list.
Each assignment will show
the title of the activity,
the class name, the due date and time,
and the status of the assignment.
If the assignment is a video
or article, it will show
as "Completed" or "Not Completed."
If the assignment contains questions,
it will show the student's best score.
By clicking on the assignment
name or the status,
which will show as a "Start"
button for new assignments,
the student will be taken
directly to the assignment.
If students want to
revisit past assignments,
they can click the the
tab for past assignments,
on the top of the page.
When students are actively
engaged with questions
through Khan Academy's
exercises and assessments,
students receive realtime
feedback and support.
If a student is stuck,
they are encouraged to watch a video
to help acquire the skill needed
to solve the problem or take a hint,
which walks through the
exact problem step-by-step.
Please note, if the student
chooses to take a hint,
that question will be marked incorrect,
as the final step in the hint,
is the answer to the problem.
Once a student submits an answer,
they're instantly informed if
they are correct or incorrect,
through an encouraging message to move on
to the next question
(dynamic, light tone)
or re-attempt the question
to reach the correct answer.
We hope this video provides
a better understanding
of the student experience on Khan Academy.